يا إلهي ،
هذا هو الدافع الذي يبدو مثل
[الموسيقى] ،
إنه ظلام الشتاء في
شمال غرب المحيط الهادئ ، لقد
استيقظت قبل الشمس ولأسباب وجيهة
للمشاركة في طقوس الصباح التي لا
يمكن تجربتها إلا في
سياتل.  سوق السمك ،
حسنًا ، إنه امتدادك هناك ،
نحن نذهب إلى الأعلى مطلوبًا لأن ما هو
أمامك تريد الحصول على تطور جيد
هو رمي 40 رطلاً من King
Salmon ،
إنه بارد أنت تعمل مع السمك اللزج
والجليد وفقط  مكان سهل للغاية إذا
كنت تريد أن تكون
بائسًا عندما تحصل على عدد كافٍ من الأشخاص
الذين يتماشون مع جعله
مكانًا رائعًا للعمل ، فكل شيء يبدأ
معًا ولماذا لا
يحتاج سوق السمك بايك بليس إلى القليل من
التعريف
[تصفيق]
العالم  مشهور حقًا إنه هنا منذ
90 عامًا غريبًا ،
إنه بالطبع معروف بأسماكه
ولا تنس المأكولات البحرية جرب هذا المصاص ،
لكن الطريقة التي يبيعونها بها هي التي تلفت
انتباهك
[تصفيق]
نعم
إذا كنت أبحث عن  مكان يمثل
قلب مدينة سياتل ، إذا كنت
ترغب في ذلك ، ربما لا يمكنني فعل أفضل من
سوق بايك بليس لأنه هنا
يتعايش السكان المحليون والسياح إذا رغبت في ذلك ،
وإذا كنت تريد معرفة سبب وجود
البقع في كل مكان  سيتم الكشف عن سترتي بالكامل ، حيث تم
إنشاء السوق في عام 1907 ، وكانت
طريقة للمزارعين لبيع المنتجات مباشرة
للعملاء منذ
أكثر من قرن وجزء لا
يتجزأ من هذه المدينة التي تبلغ مساحتها 900
قدم مربع
وسوق أسماك وأشخاص من  يأتون إلى جميع
أنحاء العالم لرؤيتنا ، إنه لأمر مدهش جدًا أن
هذا هو رايان سام جيسون وأندرس
بينهما أكثر من
قرن من العمل هنا ،
كان المالك القديم جون يوكوياما
هو معلمهم ثم باعهم
العمل في عام 2018.
أنت  شاهده وإذا كنت مثلي
تعتقد أنه من السهل وبعد ذلك
يمكنك أن تصرخ ، أوه ، كوهو ليوكو يوكو ،
اذهب فوق يوكو ، يا
The One That Got Away ، لم ير أحد
أنني لا أطيق الانتظار لوضع
هذا  حساب من خلال التنظيف الجاف
لنفقاتي للعودة إلى اللعبة ، أوه ، هذا
أوه ، هذه بطاقة سوداء
للجوقة ، حسنًا ، هذا كل شيء على ما
يرام ، هذه هي
فئة رجال الأعمال أمامك ،
كيف تعامل زملائك
باحترام ، فهم جميعًا يستمتعون بالتواجد هنا
[موسيقى]
علمتني المحطة الأولى شيئًا واحدًا
يمكن الاستمتاع بسحر مدينة سياتل على مدار العام ، حيث يمكن الاستمتاع
بالجواهر الخفية مثل
حدائق تشيهولي في انتظار اكتشافها بشكل
مذهل ، ولن أجرؤ على رمي سمكة
هنا ، إن غرابة كل هذه
الأناقة هي ماجيستي سياتل
الأماكن الخارجية الرائعة مع الاكتشافات الرائعة
بالداخل
[موسيقى]